which chainsaw man recently by the way
I only watched the first two episodes
and I stopped immediately because I was
like I need to wait for the whole season
to come out and I haven't had time to
watch it now because I'm watching One
Piece
in 10 years then yeah yeah no but it's
it's sick like I I'm waiting for
Thriller bark almost like Snapped me out
of it for a second and I was gonna like
that's when I watched Midland Saga yeah
um but uh you know I
I I can't wait to watch it it's so it's
it's really sick yeah all right so like
now now that we've established that
you've actually watched a hell of a lot
of animals
yeah have you already mentioned those
that those are your favorites everything
you mentioned or is there anything else
that you really really love
um we talked about this last night but I
love uh like my top animes I was
thinking about this the other day is
like Cowboy Bebop Samurai Champloo and
um I said Attack on Titan but I think
Space Dandy too [__] is that's how you
know he's a real life
that's how you know man just like the
top three are from the same director
right uh creative yeah
right I guess Yeah Yeah
from the same guy yeah yes
yeah I I never really like I never
really thought about that at all like
who makes the animes at all yeah until
like recently when I started getting a
little bit I guess like looking at it
from a more adult perspective speaking
of alcohol
okay I was just gonna say where it seems
like you know you're subconsciously
gravitated towards someone's style if a
lot of your favorite anime are by the
same director but what are you gonna say
Connor uh do you watch hentai
oh yeah good question I have that was a
real derailment right then yeah I have
okay but I have suggestions okay okay I
have suggestions on job too actually
yeah
like white guy comes to Japan he's like
this is how you should do things no I
just like I don't understand it because
like there's so much in hentai that's
just like so weird to me maybe it's
because like I don't watch like concept
of weird well I'm not even talking about
like the technical porn stuff like that
stuff is not even that's the least weird
that's not even like I'm not even
interested in that like it's whatever
but like normal hentai which is supposed
to like depict normal human interactions
for some reason always have like the
skinniest smallest dude with like a
woman that is like eight times the
dude's size with like and every time she
walks in the room her titties are
walking in for like a good two frames
before she gets into the room and like
that stuff is like kind of weird I'm
like make them look like anime
characters like why do you have to make
them so like bulbous and rotund right
and then the other thing is like the
x-ray vision I can't stand that [__] all
right yeah that is that is some people
like it some people don't I cannot I'm
like when
when have I have you ever like when
you're watching porn when have you ever
been like I wish I could cut them open
and see what they look like
I've never thought that in my life I see
that I'm like this is so medical yeah
like you know you know what I think it
is you know I think it is but I just
think a lot of consumers of hentai have
never felt perverts have never felt what
that feels like so by having the
internal shot it's like yeah it's their
imagination of like I can kind of
imagine what it feels like it looks like
this it sounds like this and the
character is describing it like this
version right so I can yeah I can go
into that guy's mind being like it
probably feels like this yeah yeah I
just I see that I'm like gross yeah
it's so it's so yeah like I said it's
like medical like it's like an x-ray
vision like why do I need to see that
sometimes it gets too detail yeah
like this like I didn't need to see the
ovaries like yeah I really did it yeah
it's like not sexual like that's what I
mean it just yeah and then like
she's so large that she could just like
suck the entire dude into her [__]
basically and it's like what the [__]
like what is happening why can't they
have like normal proportions like it's
just [__] Attack on Titans yeah just
like you know grown-up Hinata in the
[__] you know just do that that's I'm
fine with that like that that would be
great yeah okay uh mentioned the uh the
types of genres that it is it's more
often than not uh natural rare is the
most popular one oh I don't know the
genre look I'm not that into it like I'm
not well if you watch any you've
probably come across it because it's
just it's unavoidable yeah and then
normally the ones that look the best uh
do you know what this is natural no go
ahead it's your field of expertise
expertise he knows he knows he knows no
because uh netarare is basically
pronounce it
um I guess how do I even describe this
it's kind of like [__] porn you you
basically it's it depicts like someone
who is in love with a girl all you know
in a relationship with a girl and he
watches her you know getting [__] uh
it's like really popular yeah and that's
like the most the most popular genre
here in Japan yeah most like any like
any type of like voyeurism is considered
like the top dog yeah oh yeah I saw the
binocular section at the [__] at the
big whatever is yeah big camera dude
that shit's crazy they just have an
entire like section dedicated but I was
like what the [__] I mean that's mostly
for bird watching
unless you're watching a different type
of bird yeah there was an old lady
when I was there she was like testing at
the bananas I was like okay I get what's
going on yeah I don't think she's a
pervert yeah
exactly exactly yeah have you been to
any anime stores since you've been yeah
yeah I I went to akiabara and it was
awesome did you did you go to any store
that had like a curtained off section no
I haven't seen like so people have sent
me what's the there's like a it's
yeah is like the guy who makes it is a
fan of mine yeah yeah he he like came to
me at the Anime Expo was like dude you
take all this like he like he like snuck
out and he gave me a bunch of like [__]
you [__] yeah
um so I I've like you know people have
sent me like dojin's uh you know manga
in my uh in my P.O box before like I've
looked through it I just I can't like
it's too almost fascinating that I can't
like get into it you know what I mean I
don't know I don't think it's
fascinating I mean some people just
can't get into drawn like physical no I
want to bro I watch a lot of drawing
[__] like trust me yeah literally I'm
over here [__] Sweat Just dropping
down my brow I'm like come on man
so well okay so what was your what was
your contention on jav oh I mean I got a
lot I is so I mean I'm I'm very pro-sex
work I I actually uh I use a data a porn
star who like actually shot some uh porn
here in Japan too I'm friends with some
Japanese Sports I was like you know
raylo black uh being one of them even
though she doesn't shoot jav because she
has sex with black people and sometimes
that's like I guess not allowed okay
Jeff has like a lot of restrictions from
what I understand yeah from those
friendly secretive yeah it's like very
very
um yeah it's very hardcore
um but other than that kind of stuff
other than like uh the actual sex
workers perspective on it as a consumer
like I want to well there's a couple
things one blurred penises and [__]
yeah yeah [__] that [__] yeah someone
needs to be like the brave guy who just
[__] fights for that in Japan
like someone you said he diesel yeah
yeah like someone needs to be like the
guy who's like oh yeah let's do it
anti-censorship law or something and
they want to be that guy who's like all
right please vote for me by the way yeah
my main policies is you're moving don't
don't make it the man sneak it in I I
think that would either like I think it
might work I think it could work or like
it would either backfire or immediately
get you elected there's no way
no I want to teach like I want to talk
to the Japanese people out here like I
know AOC and a bunch of AOC and a bunch
of like American politicians like came
to Japan recently like right as I was uh
coming in yeah yeah because I was I was
actually going to originally do a
podcast with her here because I was like
thinking like you know we're both here
we'll link up here yeah then I was like
what the [__] I could just do it in
America it doesn't matter
um but they came and talked to some
politicians and I was like [__] I want
to be one of those envoys who like
teaches uh you know sneaky ways of
earmarking things into bills you know
what I mean go to the wait how do you
say is it diet or diet diet I think diet
yeah yeah just go to the diet and just
[__]
pass legislation that is completely
unrelated but then hide that [__] in
there you know
yeah I would like to say something yeah
just like
sneak it in
even mention it everyone will be like
wink wink nod like No One's Gonna and
they're not killing orphan bills I did
sneak in a no blurring Pawn rule yeah
Sue me yeah and then because this always
works in America because then if people
say oh wow this is there's a no dick
there's a dick blurring law in here you
could be like you want orphans to die
like nobody nobody wants to be against
the don't murder orphansville you know
what I mean wow you want to talk about
unrelated things like dicks and [__]
that's kind of weird bro we're talking
about not killing orphans here so you
have to do that
um so that's one problem I have with jab
and then the other one is like they just
look so sad
I think they look so sad when they're
doing it that that is one problem I have
as well they they look and sound like
they're in pain yeah yeah and it's like
it's not hot yeah I've never been able
to fire one off the jab for that reason
like I want to because like the actors
are beautiful they're like three hours
long so it's yeah it's way harder to
like scrub through it yeah they've had
that [__] out like a dragon bowler yeah
some of the jobs for trying to like put
a proper storyline in there dude this
Jabs that are like full-on like episodic
Series yeah and that has like a a an a
plot and a b plot yeah it's like saying
how much work they put into the story
how much they care about that but I
ain't got three hours of me to jack off
now oh well they also need to man the
camera works so bad they need to get
some like American Producers out here
like go to I agree with that too like
the angles are not doing anybody
favorite no there's just always terrible
there's a lot the amateur thing kind of
works though I don't know maybe it works
in the favor for it maybe I mean clearly
I mean it must be like it's very
successful and very popular in Japan so
it's very popular I think in China as
well oh really really well in China yeah
I think I think China has like started
doing their own like they they Market it
as job I think but it's not but it's not
like and and they they don't have they
don't censor it because I've seen that
that's how you tell the difference yeah
no literally like they I think they they
do that and then another thing I know
like they they shoot it in the
Philippines sometimes right like they'll
get like Japanese actresses to shoot in
the Philippines so they can like
override the jab rules oh [__] yeah I
know a lot about the mechanics of porn
and because of like my tricks you're
like God the [__] Supply dude no no
no it's just like I know about it
because like my advocacy for sex work so
like it's it's very it's very detailed
and very interesting when you think
about it but as a consumer when I look
at it I'm just like bro you are so sad
yeah like I can't I don't want to jerk
off I want to help you like what's going
on
what's happening like I'm I'm expecting
like a taken style situation for like
Liam Neeson burst through the door it
doesn't have to be a white guy but like
you know burst through the door and like
saves her and then they [__] in a loving
way you know what I mean yeah I never
understood Japanese censorship laws when
it comes to like pornography yeah
because you look at some stuff that in
hentai and someone like something like
the most [__] up decrepit [__] you can
think of but don't shoot the penis
what's that what's the originated from
certainly with America or something
being involved I can't believe it was
see I'm trying I'm trying to remember
because I remember I they covered this
in naked director yeah I feel like they
changed it preemptively I think I
thought it predates like uh even like
post World War II Japan I thought it was
like yeah because all the all
traditional paintings yeah like because
like the UK looks like the kind of like
the pornographic paintings from like the
Edo period we're all wrong everything
was out too much too much in America
instilled puritanical values Japan too
that's so [__] up yeah well the reason
tentacle 10 hentai exist was because
that was that yeah their way to get
around censorship because which is why I
thought it was it predates it because I
thought hentai existed before like uh
tentacle porn existed right well while
the tentacle concept was from this
ukulele from I think it's like the 1700s
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah but like I think uh yeah when
when the modern stuff came out yeah yeah
because like back back in that painting
the tentacles didn't look like penises
but they figured out that they could
make something look yeah if something
looks like a penis but technically isn't
a penis we don't need to blur that out
exactly and so that was the way they got
around that yeah that's [__] up like
that's just like that's that sucks they
just show the penises yeah like also
just like some some of the hentai and
like JV I've seen the sensory is just so
lazy to the point where it's like it's
no secret what's behind the scenes yeah
like I know what's happening it's so bad
for the Judas to sense of three yeah
yeah because you look at the sunship and
you realize that someone's job foreign
[Music]
definitely loved their jobs because you
can always tell there's always the the
air the surface area of the sun ship
some are just like cutting it close and
some are just like we're just gonna
cover half the [__] boy whatever man
I don't get paid enough for this year
that's a master in his craft yeah right
so it was America well they did it like
preemptively Central America no they
they like their businesses around the
same America's done a lot of [__] up
[__] the Japan
not a controversial take
that was like so the Meiji period the
Pacific War did have like a part during
the uh to censor like a lot of like yeah
so it's the major restoration right
which is basically where Japan started
incorporating Western like uh you know
political uh values and stuff like that
that is the most common that is
literally the entire planet like you're
like even I mean I've talked about this
before not to get too political but like
I talk about this on my stream all the
time or like
homosexuality for example in like the
ottoman era in turkey or even in like
the Mena region was not even considered
like it was just like normal mode of
existence you know people are gay who
gives a [__] whatever and it's like
Western attitudes that that against
homosexuality uh that that stem back to
like I guess the the Dark Ages and you
know wanting to make sure that like you
know a
father and a wife like a you know a
father and a mother stayed together
instead of like going out and [__]
dudes uh so that they could have as many
children as possible so they could
repopulate at a time when like children
were just like dying Non-Stop and you
needed more Farm hands that culture and
that attitude absolutely uh it was was
the reason why so many so many cultures
even all the way out here in the Far
East are are homophobic yeah like I'm
not just kidding enough on this no yeah
it's just it's interesting to think
about that like it's so it's such a
powerful uh it's such a powerful thing
that you know you just slowly but surely
change the way people view their you
know daily existence and then they take
it on themselves and and you know and
that's how you get blurred dicks and
penises and Japanese adult video God
damn it it's [__] up that's it's all
those farmers in the Dark Ages man if it
wasn't for them yeah we would have been
it's like farmers in the Dark Ages
die yeah it's [__] up yeah Jesus it's
the church man they need to they [__]
ruined everything
yeah because censorship had a well back
in the top of our period as well it's
like Christianity is like so they have
to sense it yeah and bad all those books
away from people oh yeah yeah okay
all right I'm Christian yeah that's
[__] up